[Music]
Mama's dick
and it's Friday I'm looking at myself
and kind of just surprised like boo how
do you feel about the sort of strapless
look I am more open to it seeing it Dan
I originally thought my mom's pick
doesn't have the dramatic back it is
strapless which I don't know if I want
to go that route I have scars and I
still have my port and from chemo you
ready to guys see what everybody thinks
let's do this do it
[Music]
my mom is sick mom is paying I love it
she knew you picked it right away I love
the dress on her I feel like it's more
my choice and I thought it was beautiful
it's a very safe dress yes yes okay I'm
about to burst
there's more surprise one lorry so it's
time yes there's somebody that's very
special to me that has a concert here
tonight and she it works very closely
with the LLS society we know how
important music has been to you and
still continues to be right oh yeah wait
you're not gonna believe he's here
[Music]
Hilary Scott from Lady Antebellum
[Music]
oh my gosh Hilary's got from Lady
Antebellum is here I listened to them
for a year during my chemo treatment
you're pretty special it really has been
good there's just been so much
generosity around me and it just truly
continues to keep on coming it was
really hard to keep it a secret um there
were many moments that I had to keep my
mouth shut but it was worth it anything
we can do to walk closer to a cure it's
something really really close to my
heart my bandmates oppose I've had
cancer touched their families way too
closely so thankful that you get to walk
down the aisle and a gorgeous gown to
the man of your dreams it's just gonna
be an incredible year for you I'm
believing that and praying that and I'm
just so excited for you Thank You
Hillary when we found that perfect dress
you're gonna say what you look good
[Music]